bienvenidos de nuevo espero que a estas
alturas ustedes tengan un mayor
entendimiento y puedan inferir estas
soluciones por su cuenta ya que pasamos
mucho tiempo calculando qué tan rápido
va la pelota ahora veamos qué tan alto
llegó ya que es algo también muy
interesante de conocer nos dimos cuenta
que la velocidad inicial es igual la
velocidad inicial es igual a menos g
por ti
entre 2
si decimos que g es igual a menos 10
metros sobre el segundo al cuadrado
entonces tenemos que velocidad inicial
es igual a 5 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado por el tiempo
la velocidad final resulta la misma que
la velocidad inicial
entonces bueno ahorita tenemos
queremos saber qué tanto o qué tan alto
llegó en esta trayectoria nuestra pelota
y ve el punto de que tan alto llegó es
justo aquí en este vértice de la
parábola
así que lo podemos calcular con la
fórmula del vértice de la parábola pero
en esta ocasión vamos a calcularlo de
manera más intuitiva en lugar de usar
fórmulas queremos saber la altura que
vamos a eliminar con la letra h
y bueno vamos a una velocidad inicial
llegamos a una velocidad intermedia y
luego bueno a esta velocidad intermedia
es igual a cero
a la que alcanzamos en un tiempo de 0
entre 2
tenemos que nuestra velocidad inicial es
igual a menos g por 30 entre 2 y también
conocemos el tiempo que es el tiempo de
0 entre 2 que es la velocidad de cambio
de velocidad inicial a cuando llega a la
velocidad cero entonces cuál es nuestra
velocidad promedio en este tiempo
recordemos que sólo en esta primera
sección
de nuestra gráfica no es el periodo
completo y vamos a cambiar de color para
darle variedad a esto
la velocidad promedio durante este
tiempo va a ser la siguiente velocidad
promedio es igual a mi velocidad inicial
más la velocidad final que es la
velocidad final en este punto es 0 / 2
vamos a sustituir nuestro lo que tenemos
aquí como velocidad inicial y tenemos
que la velocidad promedio es igual a
menos
por qué
entre 2
con estos términos y nos queda que es
igual a menos g de cero
entre 4
recordamos que esto es sobre la mitad
del periodo ya que la velocidad promedio
en todo el periodo es igual a cero aquí
podemos ver la diferencia entre rapidez
y velocidad pues como es posible que la
velocidad promedio sea cero en este
periodo si vimos que por la pelota tenía
bastante rapidez la mayor parte del
tiempo
esta es la diferencia pues tienes razón
en que la pelota iba muy rápido la mayor
parte del tiempo pero si tomamos la
velocidad promedio vemos que durante
todo el tiempo
estuvo la velocidad en esta parte
positiva esto se cancela con todo el
tiempo que pasó la velocidad en siendo
obtener un valor negativo por lo que el
promedio durante todo este período va a
ser igual a cero
así que bueno este es sentido porque la
pectina sentido porque la pelota
finalmente salió y regresó al mismo
punto
entonces recordando que la velocidad es
un vector y la dirección importa pues
bueno aquí tenemos que la velocidad
promedio es 0 aunque es la rapidez es
diferente de ser y aquí es una
aplicación donde vemos la diferencia
entre rapidez y velocidad entonces
conocemos la velocidad promedio en este
periodo y también conocemos el tiempo de
interés de 0 entre 2 así que ahora
podemos usar la fórmula que la
diferencia en distancia va a ser igual a
la velocidad promedio por el tiempo
sustituimos
y usamos nuestra velocidad promedio que
acabamos de inferir que es menos
de 0 entre 4
por el tiempo de interés que este
subíndice 0 entre 2 x
de 0 / 2
y entonces haciendo estas operaciones
tenemos que la altura de interés es
menos
porte 0 al cuadrado entre 8
si yo lanzo una pelota y digamos que le
toma cinco segundos subir y bajar
lo sustituimos en la fórmula y tendremos
que la altura en este caso es menos
menos la gravedad que es menos diez
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
por el tercero que es 5
al cuadrado
entre 8
este menos con este menos se cancela 5
al cuadrado es 25 y 25 por 10 es igual
recuerdo que son cinco segundos por lo
que estos también son cinco segundos al
cuadrado y cancelamos con estos de
manera que me quedan 250 metros entre 8
y esta división me da 31 metros
entonces si yo lanzara la pelota y ésta
se quedara en el aire durante 5 segundos
le habría lanzado a 31 metros de altura
puede no sonar muy alto pero es casi tan
alto como un edificio de nueve pisos así
que es bastante alto y si lo logran
quiere decir que son muy fuertes
quiero enseñarles algo muy interesante o
al menos a mí me parece interesante
y vamos a cambiar el color para ver esto
tenemos que entonces que nuestra altura
es igual a menos g
0 al cuadrado / 8
pero también podemos escribir esto como
menos g por tc de cero entre 2
al cuadrado entre 2
a caso de esto les parece familiar por
supuesto esto es lo mismo la ecuación de
distancia si tenemos que la diferencia
en distancia es igual a la velocidad
inicial
por el tiempo más la aceleración por el
tiempo al cuadrado entre dos pues vemos
que estos dos términos
pues son equivalentes sobre todo cuando
la velocidad inicial es igual a cero
cómo se relaciona esto bueno una manera
diferente de ver esta misma información
es qué
cuando lanzamos
o tenemos esta distancia h
la calculamos hacia arriba cuando la
lanzamos va subiendo hasta esta
distancia
bueno esta es la misma distancia que
podemos recorrer pero hacia abajo cuando
va cayendo la pelota
si decimos que iniciamos en este punto
en el vértice de la parábola entonces
podemos decir que es lo mismo que
dejamos caer la pelota ya que en este
punto la pelota está quieta y comienza a
bajar es como si la soltaremos directo
de un
edificio de con una altura h que es la
que tenemos aquí
entonces si dijéramos que vamos a dejar
caer la pelota desde una altura h cuánto
tiempo tardaría en llegar hasta el suelo
bueno entonces podemos usar esta fórmula
de la diferencia de la distancia con la
velocidad inicial por el tiempo que
bueno aquí nuestra velocidad inicial
sería cero porque la vamos a dejar caer
y bueno en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
sustituir y terminar de hacer el cálculo
de este problema